très flamme devant avait égalé un peu
vers la gauche en effondrant les
marcheurs sur l'usiné hockey l'espoir
est intéressant lui disais ça implique
bien taillée cancer et en savès de tf1
au capital de fourrure ou il ya des
brillants sur le jeu peut avoir un peu
sans te marrer voilà peu de chance vous
inscrire
ouais moi je parle pas passionnant
vraiment un truc comme ça bouge pas du
goût d'un attentat et riez pas ce que ça
va frôler toussaint on est loin encore à
moi qui grâce aux tournois plus les
jours peut-être là-dessus à l'arrêt pour
arriver avec on peut donc augmenter le
faisais et je lui sais quel camp tu des
études est petit et épique et tu vas
versé vers la gare d'où l'attrait plus
petit lac devant ken jury reste un grand
vide
maintenant qu'on montre encore un peu ou
pas en soi sortir pour la paix
photo photo le jock locaux voilà quelle
heure les camions devant avec le lac
passe au dessus des pics et tu laisses
envers le pain les gens vers le bac
étant concentrés dans la city les gros
camions voilà c'est des gros camions et
j'avais partenaires ça la gauche je ne
saurais trop vous passerez déséquilibre
il faut c'est très bien qu'ils soient
rempart de son corps plus bas récents
plus bas
ces déséquilibres à la prudence en
raison du genre tu les vois on la voit à
gauche je vois mal à empathie mal ça
bien c'est conscient ben mercer de 30 en
cinq ans qui ne m'intéresse pas beaucoup
lusine laser manche une usine qui elles
mêmes à caen il ya les mêmes partout à
dos 1 les mêmes partout maintenant je
prends le train urbain trop sur mer
d'aller même pas je pense le grand
talent face à l'aller 2-1 pas la couper
de son paysage tu vois pas qui peut
remettre
et tout le bordel derrière un pack est
intéressant moi
je vais vers les camions labaki
travaille en poche de sa veste verte rue
jean gabriel allait pas mal en contre
jour là les bêtes se parlent
bien vers les torcher albert la pub r
les corps des enfants de ben voilà voilà
fin prêt pour voilà
voila voila tempère beauplan face et pau
là je suis d'accord avec toi
voilà là là c'est bien bien
c'est pas un peu sur l talents souvent
pauvres
porter prendre
voir occupait remet un peu voilà
on arrive l'arrière jeunesse pire est à
venir ça voilà la fumée
hop